[Music]
the national conversation about race
includes the u.s military defense
secretary mark esper has effectively
banned the confederate battle flag from
bases and installations but that's only
part of the issue in a 2019 survey more
than half of people of color serving in
uniform said they had personally
witnessed white nationalism or racism in
the military
according to the defense department
around 17 percent of u.s
troops identify themselves as black we
spoke with several former active duty
service members of different races and
religions
about their experiences and as a black
woman i had to wonder okay
is this happening because i have ovaries
or it's because i have melanin
10-year army veteran mary tobin says
racism in the ranks
often isn't camouflaged
as a student leader at west point tobin
had to inspect cadet's rooms
you come in with a white glove and of
course you check for dirt
and she quickly found a red flag two
white men who were roommates
i walked in and there was a very large
confederate flag
i saw the flag i looked at them they
looked at me
and i could tell they were trying to get
a reaction out of me
that happened two more times and finally
um i had a discussion with them and told
them about how that felt for me as a
black woman from the south
coming into the room every inspection
and seeing that flag
it hurt me dearly now nearly two decades
later
the confederate flag is no longer
allowed at west point
but tobin says reminders of that painful
past remain
one example is the name of a barracks
named after general lee i lived in that
in those barracks
at west point there's lee barracks
there's lee gate there's lee
road there's robert e lee housing area
enough
just before bronze star recipient dana
patard graduated in 1981
he overheard two fellow cadets call him
the n-word
one of them ran after me and said oh hey
dana i am i'm so sorry
i said what are you sorry for i'm so
sorry for calling you
i was so shocked i thought i i
cannot believe that and then i took both
of them aside and said
we are two months from graduation west
point and you
still only see me as a
batard went on to carry the nuclear
launch codes for president clinton
and command all u.s forces in iraq it
makes me wonder well
what else are they saying when you're
not around or when i'm not around
and did you ever worry about that not
really because my assumption is
they probably did we've got to
collectively work together
if we're going to end this legacy of
systemic racism
and it's going to take more than black
people to do that for the first time
african-american officers lead the air
force and west point
but this photo taken last fall shows the
lack of diversity among the military's
top ranks
the chances of me making a fulbert
colonel or general become less and less
likely
as i look at my competition
and those who are making a selection and
really feel like
there's no one representative of me
captain george bates said he was passed
over for promotion
early in his 27-year air force career i
knew i had more work experience
time in service education
my caucasian competitor has struggled
with the air force fitness test
and was still promoted i was praised
for how i handled the bad news as if to
say they thought i would be aggressive
or disgruntled captain tobin faced a
triggering moment when she said
a white superior dressed her down with
his hand on his gun
and i said sir could you please remove
your hand from the trigger well
and he goes well why why are you afraid
of my hand on a trigger wheel is it
because you're from the hood
is this what you're you're used to
you're used to people shooting at you
but others believe there has been
progress over the years
like retired marine platoon assad and i
think that
race is one of the things that the
military gets right more often than
wrong in compared to
our civilian counterparts saad a muslim
met her husband
evan in the marine corps openness
diversity
inclusion those are all byproducts of
serving in the military because
you're bringing young adults from all
over the country
with their own personal experiences from
their corner of the world
and you're putting them together and
that's why they all
encourage young people to serve
diversity makes us stronger
can we be a better country yes but
america
is worth fighting for and worth serving
we asked to talk to active duty troops
the pentagon declined but in a statement
said it's taking a holistic look to
address diversity
and increase inclusivity in the ranks
adding these efforts
strengthen our military readiness and uh
anthony and michelle i just also wanted
to point out that
west point graduated its first cadet in
1877 that was henry
o flipper it was almost half a century
later before the next graduate would
leave west point and that was personal
hero of mine
benjamin o davis jr who of course would
go on to lead
the famed tuskegee airmen earning four
stars as a general in the united states
air force but throughout his whole time
at west point he was shunned so for four
years while he was at west point
no one spoke to him except in an
official capacity
and i can only imagine the grit and the
fortitude and the discipline
that you would need to complete a
program like that with no one
speaking to you in 2015 west point
didn't name a barracks
for general davis yes well still so hard
to believe that they have
barracks named assistant this is new
york
for general robert well more than just
the barracks it was
there's the gate there's like four
different things that bear his name at
west point and that being said um the
military though
should be credited because as as a
couple of those
people mentioned you know it is it is
fought for diversity
and affirmative action on many fronts
and in many ways it has been needed out
front
yeah yeah in this country yeah as but
still also
let me add something to that let me add
something to that uh the military
uh first desegregated its ranks in 1947
almost everyone we spoke to
said that they in some instances have
experienced
uh things that have happened to them
worse in the civilian world
the military reflects what happens in
the civilian world
at some levels uh but uh oftentimes they
experience
uh things in the civilian world that
they do not experience in the military
all right thanks vlad